actually remember being absolutely
petrified
to tell my boss that i was pregnant the
recruitment mentors podcast is proudly
sponsored
by vincerie who are weaponizing
recruiters
through tech and the award-winning sauce
breaker who are
transforming the way recruiters work and
you know being probably a little bit
secretive because
you just didn't know what was then was
your desk going to be take away from you
what was going to be the consequence of
that
um going back and and that's what
happened my desk was taken away from me
um and i was also promised a couple of
bonuses
um that then i didn't receive for women
your confidence is that the lowest error
ever is coming back after a maturity
leave
you've got absolutely absolutely and you
know that needs to be recognized by
leaders
and you need to support these women into
um coming back into an environment that
they can manage
they're daunted by having to leave their
world in the first place
and then how on earth are they going to
have the juggle that
how do you master that how do you master
being the best at work
being a handbook it is so so so
difficult
um and so our jobs as leaders is to make
other people's jobs as
easy as we possibly can not harder